my name is Pierce County MI
post-doctoral scientists in a market of
research Cambridge computational science
library and today I'm going to talk
about our geo database application that
we've been developing to help scientific
expert of the IUCN collecting
information and threats of species the
IUCN is the oldest and largest
environmental organization and it starts
with gathering information on extension
risks to species and one of the piece of
information they're after is a spatial
map of threatened species and they
wanted a very easy to use powerful tool
to allow scientific experts to put in
put these special threats to
biodiversity and so we're develop these
online application that is got a big map
front end and a sequel server 2012 back
ends and the way this works is that
allows for two fundamental functionality
one is to find information on the
special and textual data base and the
other one is provide extra information
so first let's start by using the query
functionality say we want to know where
did you where the gorilla species or the
word leave so we just type your gorilla
we'd search and we are presented with
two results the two gorillas species of
the world the mountain in the lowland
gorilla species we can actually see the
distribution on the world where do they
occur and this is essentially crunching
lots of spatial data from the crowd to
provide us with a spatial map of where
the mountain gorillas lives and say we
want to simulate the functionality of
adding a spatial map say we are a group
of scientific experts happen to know
about threats to gorillas we want to add
this information is as easy as to click
here another sustenance select threats
and the name the threat we want to add
so let's say this is gorilla poaching
then we hit here on start assessment and
then the two information that these app
needs are spatial data so where these
occur and what kind of threats are we
talking about let's start by adding a
special map so again thinking of us as a
group of people that work in as part of
guerrilla now in a workshop but we can
collectively draw on map where the
poaching occurred and because this app
runs a line we can actually not
necessarily be physically together in
the same workshop but be virtually
connected and working on the same
project and edit the boundaries of this
polygon together so once you have the
spatial distribution of the stretch we
identify what kind of tractors this is
ian has created our categories ational
threads and I happen to know that
poaching is five point one point three
and we can add information about timing
so if he's on going with its past threat
also a description and supplemental
information such as a video or a photo
of poaching and curry in the region and
then we can also add information on what
species are impacted by the stretch and
this is a very neat functionality that
essentially allows as to overlay this
shape that we just draw against the
distribution of any other species that
are is in there are base so we do that
by going on species impact and so we
want to know if there is any other great
ape not only their mountain gorillas any
other grade there occur in the region
because we may believe that actually
poaching is not only focusing on a
mountain grill about any ater is there
this simple as just writing down the
name of the great apes so they owe me
need a fellow milling and and just click
there and what this is doing essentially
just very fastly from the cloud
overlaying the special polygon with the
distribution of all or media species and
as just told us that they still down
there occur in the region one is the
mountain gorilla which when you are
ready and the other one is the
chimpanzee and then as experts we can
just decide whether we think the species
impacted or not and we can just toggle
this from not impacted to impact it and
then publish this and once this is
published essential is already online
and available
for us to search for it so say we want
to search all threats that occur in for
example random and we search for this
the result is immediately available for
us here and we can return the result
that we just added to this database so
now we created this map we saved it and
this is already available for any
scientific experts to query against it
edit it and consulted in order to think
about the extinction risk of gorillas
and also think about conservation
measure to protect a gorilla and so the
idea is that is a online map is going to
be available for scientific expert to
support the IUCN in doing its job and we
as Mars of research Cambridge are very
proud to be able to support this thank
you